hello everyone Bulgin here so the
following gameplay is a community played
it of scp-610 gesture day to be streamed
to celebrate 1000 members on my desk
cord those of you who tuned in to the
stream know that that didn't work out
because my internet completely failed
and I couldn't stream but I still played
and recorded what I played so as a way
of an apology I'm uploading this video
now I just still that is know what went
on unfortunately I had to add it a lot
of a night because as as it is with me
50% of the time I was running a bite on
my own lost so it's being very heavily
added at dine to make it moderately
entertaining anyway join my discord if
you haven't already it's a really good
way to interact with me apart from the
comment section and let me know if you'd
like me to host a secret laboratory like
community played it for lack of a better
word Dustin's ridiculous but a community
played it with everyone in the discord
at least once a month I think that would
be a pretty cool thing to have regularly
let me know in the comments or on this
court because honestly I'd really like
to do that as well it was really fun
playing with everybody last night so I'm
I digress I'm rambling here well they
further ado here's the gameplay I hope
you enjoy it oh yeah what do we got here
can I see you
yeah let's do this we've gotta wait well
sweep 294 says it requires a coin so
we're gonna have to find a coin I don't
think he can input a custom code okay I
don't know I want sweep hey what's up
I don't know
there was a scientist night around here
[Music]
yeah get some ammo really so we have we
have to get you out then so yeah let's
see we can find our way back now whoops
this is an ETF unit you know it kills
insurgency anyway plus D please
hello is anyone there
yeah supposed to do because I tried to
do because I tried locking the doors on
people to try and trap them move SCPs
didn't work
yeah the lock doesn't work I tried the
deer as well but they just opened the
door anyway yeah which is I find kind of
pointless thing because you just a
camera on you for the ESPYs but then you
can't like talk to them that was really
weird cuz I spawned I actually spawned
inside your mouse there and all I seen
was teeth when I spawned my moose Hindi
you for really oh my god
this is weird watching him it's almost
like he's looking through walls yeah he
got me - yeah I just died Hubert Moscow
after the other guy
scp-106 okay cool let's see can I put my
thing down here does it work
nope did a good time
yeah okay it's a relatively
inconspicuous place to put this is that
again yes Yuval new sex rican tainment
procedure override okay then is there
gonna be somebody
think they are yes you're me I can hear
you it's me it's Volgin okay you're a
computer man yeah I'm 106 there thought
I heard someone are their own okay
yeah good stuff I haven't seen pretty
much anybody the entire time I've been
here I'm not even worried
[Music]
ah
at least I got two people ripped so I'm
starting to notice a pattern here anyone
who's on Hubert's team wins it's
interesting that he wins every one the
game
it's me it's vowel gun yeah this doesn't
really bode well for you mitt sorry yeah
hey witness what's meant to be there
well this is fun
okay yeah nothing although there's a
couple of things that I've noticed that
people are doing is they're actually
stunned and if there's about ten people
in that room yeah they they stand in the
iput door and wait for the thing to
spawn so they try to steal other
people's cards
oh cool
it's Lock and Load yep looks like it how
do you know okay
[Music]
okay let's go the other way oh cool nice
nice hey so what happened the nuke then
go off how you do
Sonne I couldn't I can wait down it the
warheads with because we have old five
key cards no chaos insurgency done here
[Music]
haha get rekt oh the alpha warheads
disabled somebody disabled it before it
actually happened that's all what no
there's nothing down here right just a
dead end
Oh can you skip I can skip a scientist
okay so compare is it down there that
you can escape so what happens the earth
not help that Mississippi one century
doesn't surprise us
this is the where remote that nation on
I don't even know for a man to blow this
place up but we've got nothing else to
do so oh sorry week we going the wrong
way
what's happened
well there goes the new page you win
okay well that was it
sorry about the really crappy meme I put
in but I couldn't resist
thanks very much for listening and I'll
see you all tomorrow good bye I would
like to give a special thank you to
Andre best [ __ ]
thank you very much Andre your pledge is
very much appreciated if you would like
to know how you can get a personalized
thank you at the end of each of my
videos as well as some other really cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
you